MALE SPEAKER: Please join me
in a massive round of applause
to welcoming Lord Mervyn King.
[APPLAUSE]
MERVYN KING: Well,
thank you very much.
I'm delighted to be here.
I should apologize right at
the outset for wearing a tie.
Google is actually
a lot more tolerant
in this respect than
some other places,
because I remember going,
when I was at the bank,
with some colleagues
to the Palo Alto area,
and Hal Varian, your chief
economist who's an old friend,
showed us around Mountain View.
And it was a very
civilized visit.
We enjoyed it enormously.
And then we went
off to Facebook.
And as we got to
Facebook, we were
greeted by a young woman
straight out of college
who had this missionary
zeal on her face.
And we're about four of us.
And we're all wearing
suits and ties--
from the Bank of
England, of course.
And as we walked in
to go up a staircase,
she pointed to a
picture, because they
spent vast amounts of
money in Facebook doing up
an old warehouse to make it
look like an old warehouse.
And there was a poster on the
wall with a man in, you know,
gray hair and a suit and tie.
And she pointed at this man
and said, that's the enemy.
So I'm forever
grateful to Google
for being more receptive
to people who wear ties.
MALE SPEAKER: Well, welcome.
We love ties.
I'm wearing a T.M.Lewin
shirt, which also
puts me slightly out of that.
MERVYN KING: Very impressive.
MALE SPEAKER: So what do
you see as the difference
between engineering
and economics?
We're in an
engineering building.
There's many engineers
in the room here.
And you were saying
economics perhaps started out
as a scientific
engineering subject.
MERVYN KING: Well after the
Second World War, it did.
I think that what was very
striking in the early 1960s
was that there was an
influx of mathematicians
and natural scientists
into economics.
And people wrote highly
mathematical treatises
and the old idea of
the invisible hand,
Adam Smith, Paul Samuelson
wrote his textbook.
Highly mathematical.
And economists got more and
more excited about the fact
that they could be
like scientists,
and we could make
accurate predictions.
And I remember in the
'60s, as a student,
that people were constructing
computer models of the economy
and applying control
engineering techniques to it
to optimize the
part of the economy.
So you'd choose interest
rates and fiscal policy
to optimize that
part of the economy.
And this was a tremendous,
exciting development.
And it all failed.
Completely failed.
And the reason is that there's
a fundamental importance--
and I don't think
it's fully been
grasped since-- that there
are no natural constants
in economics.
There are no laws that you
can believe hold exactly.
And one of the things
that's crucially
important in understanding
the behavior of the economy
are people's beliefs about
what will happen in the future.
Expectations.
And sometimes, these
can be pinned down
by what look like sensible or
plausible views of the world.
But other times, the future
is so inherently unknowable
that there's no rational basis
on which to form expectations
about the future.
And so in the book, what I
talk about is that people
don't optimize, they cope.
And that is the big difference,
I think, between engineering
and physics, where
you can genuinely
believe that there are laws
of nature determining paths--
you may not know what they all
are, and you try and discover
more about it, but once
you've discovered them,
they're paths-- and
economics, where
there are no fixed scientific,
immutable laws like that.
And I think economists are
deeply reluctant to admit this,
because it would pull them
back into the pack of all
the other social sciences.
MALE SPEAKER: Sure.
MERVYN KING: And
it was always very
thrilling to be thought of on
the same level as engineers
and scientists.
When you realize
actually you're not,
it becomes a bit of a shock.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
So the book is called
"The End of Alchemy:
Money, Banking, and the
Future of the Global Economy."
What do you mean
when you say alchemy?
MERVYN KING: Well the
traditional meaning of the word
alchemy is to turn
base metal into gold.
Change something
that, in reality,
isn't very valuable
into something that is.
That's clearly been true of
money down the generations.
Paper money, electronic
money, there's
no inherent value to it.
It depends on trust.
People's willingness to accept
it, and the trust of the people
issuing it.
But it's even more
true of banks,
because you put your money
in a bank that has a deposit,
the bank tells you you can take
it out whenever you want to,
to make a payment
or to have cash.
Actually if we
all did that, they
wouldn't be able
to meet the demand,
because they've used
the deposits to finance
highly illiquid loans.
So there is something-- it's
a sort of alchemy to believe
that all of us have deposits in
banks which are highly liquid
and we can use them
whenever we want.
And yet at the same time,
they're backed by something
that cannot possibly
meet that demand.
That's what I mean by alchemy.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
And by illiquid, just in
case anyone isn't clear,
illiquid means?
MERVYN KING: So the
bank would make a loan
to a household or a company
where they would say well,
I will lend to you for
10 years for a mortgage
or for an investment.
And there's no way the
bank can get the money back
until that period.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
MERVYN KING: So if someone
walked into the bank and says,
terribly sorry, I'd
like all my money out,
the bank can't then turn around
to the people it's lent to
and say, well, I know I said
I'll lend to you for 10 years.
Actually, the people that I got
the money from have now come in
and asked their money back.
So could you please
repay your loan tomorrow.
And even if they did try to ask
people to repay it tomorrow,
they wouldn't be able
to do so, and people
might have to sell
the assets that they'd
bought with the loan.
And that would be at a--
MALE SPEAKER: A lower value.
MERVYN KING: A lower value,
at a fire sale price.
So that is the ultimate
alchemy, that the banking system
pretends to people that all the
money that they put in a bank
is highly liquid, that
is you can take it out
whenever you want and use
it, whereas in fact it's
backed by investments
that are far from liquid.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
So the 2008 crisis is a
large part of the book.
How did it come
about, and how is that
related to the alchemy on
which the book is based?
MERVYN KING: So the
book is not a memoir.
It's not a blow-by-blow account.
We've got dozens
of those already.
And I didn't want to do that
because, inevitably, that's
self-serving.
If I wrote a book about
the events that happened,
it would be from my
perspective, and most of you
would be sensible to say, well,
he would say that, wouldn't he?
So I wanted to write
something about the ideas
behind this, because
it seemed to me
that the first observation
I had when I left the bank
and reflected on everything was
almost everyone in this drama
was in a prisoner's dilemma.
That is, that there was nothing
that they could do on their own
to get out of this.
But the classic
demonstration of this
was Chuck Prince, who
ran Citibank, who said
in 2007, this
famous statement he
made, while the music's playing,
we've got to go on dancing,
so we're dancing.
And within two or three
months, the music had stopped
and he lost his job.
But the interesting
point about this
was if he'd said that five
years earlier and said,
you know, I am very
nervous about all
these complex
financial instruments
that people are selling and we
don't want to do this anymore,
we're gonna get
out of this market,
we're not gonna be so
highly leveraged-- that
is, the bank was
financing itself
by too much borrowing, rather
than equity finance-- if he'd
said that, then Citibank
would have been much less
profitable in the
intervening five years,
and he would probably
have been sacked
before we even got to 2007.
MALE SPEAKER: Because
the shareholder
expectation wouldn't be met.
MERVYN KING: All the
other banks would
have been earning
a lot of money,
because they were taking risks.
So Keynes once said,
John Maynard Keynes
once said, that
it doesn't matter
what risks you take as a bank,
provided all the other banks
are taking the same risks.
And there was a similar
problem for central banks,
because there was this downward
movement of interest rates,
which started really after
the fall of the Berlin Wall
when, you know,
communism was said
to have lost out to capitalism.
Now we saw all this.
And in fact, at
the same time, what
we saw with China
and other countries
embracing a market economy
was that the number of people
working in the manufacturing
sector around the world who
wanted to export their
production probably trebled.
And that was partly
responsible for keeping wages
of most people at low levels, or
at least no increases in wages.
But it also meant
that these countries
that wanted to export a lot
were saving a vast amount.
They were saving far more
than we were willing to spend.
And so they were
putting this money
into the capital market
around the world.
It was a global capital
market for the first time.
And interest rates
determined by the balance
between saving and investment
kept pushing rates down.
And that meant that countries
like the UK and the US
were facing trade deficits,
for different reasons.
China, other countries
in Asia, on the one hand,
and Germany on the other,
wanted trade surpluses.
That meant that they were saving
more than they were investing.
We were on the other side of
that, with a trade deficit,
we were borrowing
more than we were--
we had to borrow from
the rest of the world
to finance the trade deficit.
And our debts were
spiraling upwards.
And everyone thought that
we could go on doing this.
But in the end, we couldn't.
And that's really what brought
about the crisis in itself.
So the symptom of the crisis
was that the banking system
through which these flows
of savings and investment
were mediated, the banking
system itself had borrowed
a lot of money, taken
in more deposits,
and became very fragile.
So there were many
banks that had what
are called leverage ratios.
That is, how much has
the bank itself borrowed
from other people
rather than financed
through its own shareholders.
That was 50 to 1,
which meant that if you
had a bank with, say,
$100 million of assets,
you only had to have a fall
in the value of those assets
on average by 2% to mean
the bank was literally bust,
insolvent.
MALE SPEAKER: So with
that 50 to 1 ratio,
would the healthy
amount be 1 to 1?
Is that the ideal?
MERVYN KING: I don't think we
know what the ideal ratio is.
And this is where
expectations come back,
why this isn't an
engineering phenomenon.
So ask yourself the
question, how much money
does a bank need to finance
itself through equity in order
to persuade other people that
it's safe to lend to the bank,
and they can attract funds
and do their business.
Before the crisis,
we know the answer
to that, which is hardly any.
Because banks were able
to get lots of money
from elsewhere with
very little equity.
Immediately after the
crisis, the answer
to that same question
was a hell of a lot,
because people suddenly thought,
God, banks aren't safe anymore.
And the innocence of the
banking system was lost.
And the regulators really
played no part in any of this.
This swing in sentiment
from being wildly
optimistic about
what banks could
do to being
extremely pessimistic
was a change in sentiment.
You couldn't claim that it
was obviously irrational
in any way.
People were trying to cope
with an unknowable future.
They made this judgment.
And that is the danger with
the banking system, where
if people can't get their
money out and know that maybe
if the bank is fragile they
can't get their money out,
then they may be tempted to run.
And what happened in New York
in September, October 2008,
it wasn't that ordinary people,
ordinary depositors queued up
outside the bank to
get their money out.
It was wholesale depositors.
That is, financial institutions.
Money market funds.
Hedge funds.
All said to
themselves, these banks
aren't as safe as we
thought, we get our money out
as soon as we can.
And that was the run
on the banking system
that reached its peak in
New York in that period.
MALE SPEAKER: So you mentioned
the normal day-to-day
depositors, the you and I. Do
you think that the public's
anger is justified at
bankers, and the banking
industry in general?
MERVYN KING: Well, I
don't think we should go
into this with blaming people.
I think ordinary people
are right to be angry.
But the reason they're
right to be angry
is because of a collective
failure of thinking and ideas,
rather than the behavior
of any one individual.
So Dick Fuld in Lehman
Brothers or Fred Goodwin
here in the Royal
Bank of Scotland
did not cause the
financial crisis.
It was much deeper
forces than that.
The difference
between what happened
in 2008 and the early 1930s
in the Great Depression
is that central
banks and governments
in the latter instance,
in 2008, expanded demand,
cut interest rates, to prevent
a big rise in unemployment.
And that worked.
However, that kind
of policy stimulus
is a bit like a painkiller.
It conceals the initial pain.
It brings relief.
But it doesn't deal with
the underlying symptoms.
And if all you do is to
give a patient painkillers,
they don't get better.
And in fact, it's
quite dangerous
to go on doing it too long
without tackling the underlying
symptoms.
And I think that what
people started to see
was, well, yes, we didn't see
a massive rise in unemployment.
We did see a considerable
rise, but it was
muted compared with the 1930s.
But we don't see a recovery.
We haven't got back to
where we should have been.
In fact, I would reckon
that total national income
is about 15% below where
it would have been had we
not had the crisis.
That's a staggeringly
large number.
And that's an enormous
cost of this crisis.
And therefore, there are
two conclusions from that,
in my view.
One is that this
shows the potential
for rapid growth in the future,
if we do tackle the underlying
symptoms.
And secondly, it shows why it
is that people are indeed angry,
because their living standards
have not grown as they should
have done and would have done.
And I think it's been compounded
by the fact that, certainly
in the US and the
UK, that people
were taught that a market
economy is good for you.
That it can be unpleasant
at times, you know,
if your business
isn't doing very well
and people don't want to
buy what you're producing,
the government
won't bail you out.
If you're an employee
in a company,
you might have to
accept a wage cut
rather than go on strike in
order to protect your wages.
And that's a healthy
response to enable a company
to keep employing more people.
So embracing the discipline
of a market economy
was what everyone was
told was good for them,
and would boost productivity.
And the people who were
telling this to ordinary people
most loudly were those who
worked in the financial sector.
Well, blow me.
When it comes to the financial
sector and the banks getting
into trouble, where
was the market?
Where was the discipline
of the market economy?
We all bailed them out.
Now, there were
reasons for that,
which was to protect the
economy from the banks.
We didn't want to see a
collapse of the payment system.
But you can
understand why someone
who hasn't read a lot
of financial history
or got a degree in
economics would say,
well, this is deeply unfair,
and to feel very angry about it.
And I used to have
dinners at the bank
in the immediate
aftermath of the crisis.
And I've asked people, I'd say,
why aren't people more angry?
This has got to grow
as time has gone by.
And I think that is
true, it is growing.
And the failure of
governments around the world
to deal with it
is the reason why
there is support for
extreme political parties
on both sides, both
left and right.
Doesn't matter whether
you vote left or right,
as long as you don't vote
for these guys in the middle
who, when one goes out of power
and the other one comes in,
same policy.
No change.
This unhappiness with
what's going on I
think is very serious.
And it's not going
to go away quickly.
MALE SPEAKER: And then
towards the end of the book,
you talk about ways that you
think we can restore faith
in the system.
So what do you think, in your
opinion, the kind of the way
forward is to make this system
stronger and more reliable?
MERVYN KING: I think there
are two sets of things.
One on the banking side, which,
you know, in the short run,
we've certainly made the banking
system, at least in Britain
and the United States, safer.
It's not as safe as it
needs to be, in my view,
but it's safer than it was.
And I would think, that,
over 10 to 20 years,
if we really buckle
down to it, we
could eliminate the
alchemy of the system.
And I suggest that we turn
central banks into what I call
the pawnbroker for all seasons.
In other words, instead
of waiting until a crisis
and then throwing money at
the banking system, what
we do is to say, if there's a
crisis, we will lend you money,
and you have to be in
a position that you
can borrow from us enough to
pay off all the depositors.
That will end the alchemy.
But in order to do
that, you've got
to bring to us well before
a crisis, in normal times,
your assets, like someone
would take a gold watch
to a pawnbroker.
They take the assets
on their balance sheet
to the central bank,
and the central bank
says, hm, well, you say these
assets are worth $100 million.
We are prepared, in the
future, to lend you $75 million
on these assets.
And the banks have
to pre-position,
they have to bring collateral
to the central bank,
sufficient assets that they will
have enough guaranteed credit
line with the bank that they
will always be in a position
that they can pay
off the depositors.
Then everyone would
know that there's
no point in starting a bank run,
because the bank would always
be able to go to
the central bank
and raise the money
to pay you off.
So if some people run,
that's their right,
but there's no reason
to follow them.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
MERVYN KING: Whereas
in the current banking
system, if you see people
queuing outside a bank,
the rational thing is
to get in the queue.
MALE SPEAKER: Because if
you're last in the queue,
you may not get your money.
MERVYN KING: Absolutely.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
MERVYN KING: That's the
first thing, I think.
Make the banking system safer.
The other is what do we do
about the world recovery.
And I think that
this is much harder.
It's not obvious to me
that any one country
can get out of this on its own.
This is the prisoner's dilemma.
But I do think it's two or
three things that go together.
One is that fixed exchange
rates, locking exchange rates,
has not served us well.
And that's true with
China fixing exchange rate
to the US dollar, as well as
many other Asian economies.
And it hasn't worked well within
the monetary union in Europe.
And I'll give you
one simple example.
If you take Finland, a
country in the monetary union,
it's obeyed every fiscal
rule you could think of.
No one criticized Finland for
not being prudent and tough
on the fiscal rules.
Then it had a big shock, Nokia.
Nokia was about half the
Finnish stock market.
It went down massively
in value, Russia
in deep economic trouble.
Those two things administered
a major economic shock
to Finland.
In the past, well, all
right, these things happen.
It's very unfortunate.
But there was a shock absorber,
namely the exchange rate.
And the Finnish
exchange rate would
have fallen to enable Finland to
export more and to import less.
And that would have
been a shock absorber
to keep the economy going.
There's no shock absorber now.
They can't change
the exchange rate
against any of its
major trading partners.
And so what you see is that
output is declining in Finland.
Unemployment is rising.
It has a major problem,
and no instrument
to be able to deal with it.
So I think making exchange
rates more flexible
is very important.
I think we will also need
to face up to the fact
that people discovered
in the crisis
that, in some countries,
certainly here and in the US,
we'd all been spending
more than we now realize
we should have
been spending given
the prospects for the future.
We don't want to have spent
everything out of our lifetime
incomes too early.
And it's very expensive now to
put money aside for a pension.
But, you know, we need our
pensions when we get there.
And so people are
being very cautious
now about how much they spend.
I think the only way
to deal with that
is to embark on a massive
program of raising
productivity.
This will require a
lot of small measures
different from one
country to another.
It will take many years.
But as long as people
believe that there
is a coherent and credible
plan to boost productivity
in the future,
then they'll think,
well, I'm gonna be better off in
the future than I think today,
and that means I'll
have more confidence
to be willing to spend today.
I won't run down debt as quickly
as I might otherwise have done.
And the third thing, I
think, is that the experience
of the post-war period is
that trade between countries
is fundamentally important
to boosting productivity.
We learn from each other,
we get ideas, innovations
transmitted through trade.
You can see in your field that
the flow of people and ideas
is crucial, and trade in
services as well as goods
is a crucial part of that.
So those are the things I think
we will need to embark on.
And then finally, I
do think that there
is a lack of
effective cooperation
amongst countries in the world.
And if no one country can
get out of this on its own,
we will need
greater cooperation.
And I went to all these
international meetings.
My god, they were awful.
And they cost a lot
of money to put on.
And you know, as I say in the
book, talking shops are good,
but only if the talk is good.
And it wasn't.
MALE SPEAKER: We're gonna open
up to questions in a moment,
so get some questions
in your mind.
One question for me.
In those heady days of 2008,
the late nights, all the kind
of takeaway pizzas
I imagine, what
was the most surreal
moment that you went,
I can't believe that
we're facing this.
MERVYN KING: Well
actually, we didn't
have any takeaway pizzas.
We just had glasses of water, I
think was about the only thing.
There were dramatic
moments, such as when
the Royal Bank of
Scotland rang up and said,
you know we said
last week that we
were finding it difficult to
borrow money except overnight.
Well actually, we can't
borrow overnight tonight,
so unless you give
us some money,
we'll have to close the doors.
And so I did something
which I never
thought I would do, but
effectively write out
a check for 60 million pounds.
And the only benefit
of this is that when
I've met professional
sports people subsequently,
especially footballers,
because normally they're
not very interested
in economics,
and if you've got to get
their attention somehow,
you just ask them what's
the biggest check they ever
wrote out.
And it is surprisingly
high, I must say.
It's actually surprising.
But then you trump
it with 60 billion--
MALE SPEAKER: Nice.
Nice.
MERVYN KING: --which they
have trouble understanding.
The most extraordinary
moment I think-- and it
was a bit surreal-- was after
a meeting in Downing Street
where I was with the prime
minister and the chancellor,
and I went there with
my private secretary.
And people watching
the crisis on TV
found the whole thing
rather dramatic,
but actually it wasn't quite
so dramatic in real life
when you were doing
it all the time.
It was grind.
Anyway, after the meeting,
we were coming out
of the front door of number
10 to get into the car.
And you may have seen television
pictures of people coming out
of the front door on
number 10 Downing Street.
What you don't realize probably
is that anyone coming out
of that door cannot see a
thing because they are blinded
by the lights of the television
cameras and the flashing
of the bulbs of the
print photographers.
Anyway, I knew this.
So I got my private
secretary, I said,
check that the car's outside.
He said, it's outside.
So I said to the man who stands
inside the front door in number
10 Downing Street,
the waiter there,
I said, you can
open the door now.
So he opened the door, went
out, you know, lights flashing,
the bulbs, couldn't see a thing.
But I could vaguely
see the car was there.
So I got in the car.
My private secretary went
around the other side, got
in the back on the other side.
There was then quite a
long pause before I said,
very calmly, this isn't our car.
[LAUGHTER]
There was another long
pause before we both got out
at the same moment, walked
across Downing Street
to where our car actually was,
and under the gaze of-- well,
it was no more than
three million viewers.
And ITN News ran the
headline that evening,
governor loses his way.
There are a number
of moments like that.
MALE SPEAKER: Do you
know whose car it was?
MERVYN KING: It actually seemed
to belong to the [INAUDIBLE].
MALE SPEAKER: Lovely.
So any questions
from the audience?
Mikes are coming round.
AUDIENCE: Can I start?
MERVYN KING: Why not.
AUDIENCE: So "The
Guardian" today
has a story about the fact that
intergenerational transfers
seem to be broken, so that
younger people, Generation Y,
are making a lot less
money than they should.
Is that related to 2008, is that
important, and can we fix that?
MERVYN KING: It's related
both to the causes of 2008,
and also what people have done
since to try and deal with it.
So to my mind, what
happened to the banking
system was a symptom of a
deeper underlying problem.
The cause is, in a way--
and I talk in the book
about when the Berlin
Wall fell, you know,
somebody wrote a
book, Francis Fukuyama
wrote "The End of History."
Capitalism had triumphed
over socialism and communism.
And the irony of
this is actually
it was the beginning
of a process that
led to the biggest crisis of
capitalism since the 1930s.
Why was that?
Because what was happening
in the world economy,
with the attempt to run massive
export surpluses in China
and elsewhere, was that
long-term interest rates were
just being pushed
down and down and down
as more savings were being
pushed into the capital market.
And you know, the world economy
needs positive interest rates,
partly to give an incentive
to save for the future,
partly to discriminate between
profitable and unprofitable
investment projects.
And a lot of investments
were made that turned out
to be very unprofitable.
These have yet to
be written off.
So that will be a
problem in the future.
So what happens if interest
rates keep falling?
Well the prices
of assets, assets
are simply the present
discounted value
of a future stream of earnings.
So even if you don't change your
view about the future stream
of earnings of shares
or government bonds
or the value of the
housing services
you get from a house,
merely the fact
that the discount
rate keeps going down
over a long period pushes
up the asset prices.
So it was no surprise that house
prices and stock prices, prices
of art and wine, kept going up.
However, that does create a
serious potential problem,
in that the housing stock
is always being sold.
Year by year, the older
generation, people like me,
sell their houses to the younger
generation, people like you.
And in normal
circumstances, that's fine.
The trouble is, if you've
just gone through a period
when house prices have
gone up a lot, what
happens is that the
younger generation has
to borrow much
more money in order
to finance the house purchase.
Now at one level, that's fine,
provided interest rates always
stay low.
And then people like me
sell their houses for much
more than you ever
dreamt of paying for it.
So you know, I remember
being astonished
at the mortgages that
were being taken out
by my younger colleagues, people
who worked for me in the bank.
And the biggest mortgage
I ever had in my life,
and that was only for a short
period, was 50,000 pounds.
Many of you may, I fear,
have mortgages much bigger
than that.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
Yeah.
MERVYN KING: I
never ever believed
I would be able to afford
a mortgage as high as that.
I would have been
horrified by it.
But with interest
rates so low, people
can service the mortgage.
But the intergenerational
implication of this
is that old people like
me, when we sell houses,
end up with a lot
of financial assets.
Younger people, like you,
who buy houses end up
with a lot of debt.
Now, the household sector as
a whole sort of washes out.
So if you're fortunate
enough to be in a family
where the parents say,
you know, tremendous,
I've just earned all this
money on selling the house
to your friends, so I'll
give some of you back,
so you don't have to borrow
quite so much to buy the house.
Then that's fine.
But obviously, it doesn't
work like that all the way.
And the real concern of the
younger generation, I think,
is twofold.
And I mean, I've
always said I belong
to the luckiest
generation of all.
That is, born in 1948,
I was young enough
not to have to fight in
the Second World War,
as my father did, and
young enough not even
to do national service.
But I was old enough
not to have to pay
a penny for my education.
When I was an undergraduate
at university,
there were no loans.
I even got paid a
maintenance grant
to pay for my housing and
drinks in the evening and so on.
Very generous of my parents'
generation to pay for that.
Obviously, that's all gone.
And I was also very fortunate
to have bought a house at a time
when I thought gosh,
house prices have gone up
quite a bit, so I'd
better buy a house,
but way before the
big house price rises
that happened afterwards.
And the younger
generation are stuck
with paying for education,
borrowing to finance that,
and borrowing a vast amount
to buy a very tiny apartment
or house.
Now, in the long run,
this will work out.
But the big threat, I think,
to the younger generation now--
and this is why I think
concerns are really justified--
let's suppose interest
rates start to rise.
Not now, but in 15, 20
years, just before you
start to sell your house.
Well, house prices could
come right back down again.
And the younger generation will
have been bought at the peak,
and have to sell
them at the trough.
And the other
problem, of course,
which is a really
serious issue now,
is that the pension scheme which
is offered to younger people
is so much less attractive than
the one that I was offered.
Why?
Because the interest
rate which can
be earned on the savings that
go in to provide the pension,
whether it be your
savings directly
as a defined contribution
pension scheme,
or whether it be the savings
which your employer puts to one
side through a defined
benefit scheme,
the return on those
schemes are very low.
And the obverse of high
rates putting up asset prices
is that, as interest rates
fall to where they are now,
close to zero, the cost
of providing a pension
in the future is much higher.
There is no incentive to save.
And these are very
big problems, which
is why I think it's very
important that we get back
to a normal level of interest
rates sooner rather than later.
MALE SPEAKER: So we have
about 10 minutes left,
so let's take three or four
sort of short-ish questions.
Graham, yeah, if
you pick someone.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I actually have two
questions [INAUDIBLE].
So my question is that,
I'm sure you know,
regulators have made a lot
of new regulations now.
So for example, [INAUDIBLE].
But how do we know that
the regulation is working?
I mean, like unless there is
a more data-driven approach
to the stuff, like,
how do the regulators
know that their
regulation is working?
For example, you
know, how do we know
that the leverage ratios that
the banks have now are actually
the right level?
MERVYN KING: OK, so let me
answer that very quickly.
We don't, and we can't.
And we can't.
And there's quite a
section in the book that
explains why very complicated
risk weights to calculate
the requirements for equity
capital by banks are,
in my-- I mean,
let me exaggerate,
but almost not worth the
paper they're written on.
Why?
Because they're based
on looking at past data,
which do not represent an
engineering or scientific law,
but they happen to represent a
particular set of correlations
over a period.
And when a crisis occurs,
it's because something
totally unexpected
happens, which
economists don't anticipate.
And when that happens,
the calculations
of correlations and
covariances that
go into the official regulatory
measures are irrelevant.
They don't work in a crisis.
That's why I want something
very, very simple.
And having enough
pure equity finance
is guaranteed to absorb losses.
And you'd need a lot
more of that, in my view,
in the long run, than
banks have today.
AUDIENCE: And [INAUDIBLE]
second question.
MERVYN KING: We've got some
others, I think we have--
MALE SPEAKER: Let's take
this person over here.
MERVYN KING: Come back at it
later if we have a chance.
AUDIENCE: So I
guess you probably
don't want to comment on
the [INAUDIBLE] directly.
But in 2008, we were
in the unusual position
of being in the EU
but not in the euro.
And so that gave you some
freedoms in terms of strengths.
Can you comment on how much
difference did it make to you,
being in that position?
MERVYN KING: Yes, I
can certainly do that.
And indeed, there
are quite a lot
of countries in the European
Union that are not in the euro.
And I think that will continue.
And one of the problems that
the EU needs to face up to
is the fact that it needs to
recognize much more explicitly
than it's done so far that there
are indeed two types of member,
those in the euro,
and those not.
The real benefit to us
in not being in the euro
goes back to what I said
about Finland earlier.
In 2009, Sterling fell quite
sharply, by around 25%.
And that did enable
us to see a benefit
by having higher exports
and lower imports
than we would
otherwise have done.
The trade position did improve.
That was not enough to generate
a satisfactory recovery,
because the euro area
was growing very weakly,
and that's our biggest
trading partner.
So I do think that having
that exchange rate flexibility
is important, and I
think it's important
that other countries get
back to that, as well.
That was when the world
economy worked, in my view,
more efficiently.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thanks very
much for your talk.
To your point before
about how economics
lacks fixed laws in the way of
science and engineering, myself
and my friends worry about
all our hard-earned savings,
putting it down as a house
deposit and for there
to be a recession or a
crash, and house prices
to fall literally overnight.
So would you say just kind
of don't worry about that
and go for it because,
essentially, you have to,
or are there any kind of, like,
tips or advice that you have,
given what's happened
in recent years
in terms of investing
and buying property?
MALE SPEAKER: How
can we all get rich?
AUDIENCE: Or just
not really poor.
MERVYN KING: Yes.
I think that's a
better question.
And I think there are no
simple ways of becoming rich.
And I'm always struck by you
go into an airport bookstore
and you see some book by
a famous industrialist,
you know, my advice on
how to succeed in life.
No one ever writes a book
saying boy, was I lucky.
And in fact, there's an awful
lot of that in the outcomes
that determine relative rewards.
I'd probably be
arrested if I tried
to give investment advice
without having a qualification
to do so from the regulator.
But I think there
are no simple rules.
There's no mechanical way
of guaranteeing returns.
And certainly, if
anyone says to you,
I really know a great
investment, just
be deeply, deeply skeptical.
I would suggest that it is very
important to put money aside
for a pension.
And I think that, if you
are sensible and careful,
and find a property
that you think
you'll be able to afford
over 20, 30 years,
then that is a good investment.
The key thing is to
avoid-- if you're
going to move frequently,
then rent, don't buy,
because the cost of
buying and selling
is so horrendously high.
But I have no simple
advice, and I can't claim
to be an investment expert.
But you know, don't
be too greedy,
and don't let other people
manage your money for you.
So what I find
quite astonishing is
that there are big
institutional investors,
like pension funds, who
have decided to put money
into a hedge fund that, at least
until recently, would typically
say yeah, we've got these
very smart, clever people,
and we can make more
money than you'll ever be
able to work out how to make.
And all you have to
do is to pay off fees,
and our fees are 2% of the
capital value each year.
That's 20% of the profit.
Now, if you think about some
investment earning 5% a year,
and you have to pay two of those
five percentage points in fees,
plus another fifth,
another one in the profits,
so that's-- at least five
percentage points return
on the asset, three
goes into fees.
And the interesting
thing about that
is, if you just think about
the law of compound interest,
that instead of
growing at 5% a year,
your investment's
growing at 2% a year.
You've only got to be in
this fund for 5, 10 years.
And most of the money
that's been earned
has gone to the fund
managers and not to you,
even though it's
your money that's
financing the investment.
So I'd be very, very cautious
about investing your money
when other people are
making the decisions.
MALE SPEAKER:
Particularly when they
don't have any skin in the game,
which seems to be one of the,
like, their money's not at risk.
MERVYN KING: So the
person who obviously
has the best investment
record over a long period
is Warren Buffett.
Now actually, it
hasn't been very good
in the last couple of years.
And he's very old now.
He's worrying about
who to hand it onto.
But over 40, 50
years, what he did
was to say, if you
buy shares in my,
you know, management fund, I
don't charge fees or anything.
You become shareholders with me.
And I own some of the shares in
my company, Berkshire Hathaway.
And he bought lots
of other companies.
And he had the basic,
sensible rule of thumb.
He only ever bought
things he understood,
and where he could judge whether
someone was a good manager.
So never invest in something
you don't understand,
and never invest
in something where
other people are charging you
fees for managing your money.
MALE SPEAKER: Great.
Let's take a question
from over here.
AUDIENCE: So if the UK does vote
to leave the EU, what will be
the impact to the [INAUDIBLE]?
MERVYN KING: Well, that comes
awfully close to, you know,
asking me what my view would be.
And I don't want to do that.
I did it in an interview
with BBC earlier today.
I had a very interesting
experience in the village
I live in.
Sometimes people come
up and say, you know,
what do you think of this new
man of the Bank of England,
and what you think
about interest rates?
But when it comes to
the question of Brexit,
they do not say to me, so how
do you think we should vote?
What they say is--
because they do not
want to be told or even advised
by former governor of the Bank
of England, or for
that matter anybody
else, which way to vote.
What they do want is,
what are the arguments,
what are the facts.
They want facts and
arguments to enable them
to make up their own minds.
This is a very important
national question.
People should make
up their own minds.
And what is so awful about
this campaign is that people
are treating it as a
kind of PR campaign
where you look in the
newspaper and some list,
whether it's industrialists
or financiers,
it will be footballers
and film stars soon,
you know, which
side are they on.
And I think this is
completely valueless.
And what I want is to have-- and
I said this in the interview--
the BBC has a big
responsibility here
to set out all the
arguments and all the facts.
We've got four months before
we have to make up our minds.
There's no rush on this.
So that people can go away,
think it through, and decide
and then cast their vote.
Because if we don't
do it that way,
my worry is that
it could be rather
like the Scottish referendum,
in which the referendum didn't
actually settle anything.
I don't think this referendum
took the issue off the table.
It's still there.
And that's in part because it
was fought as a PR campaign,
with both sides exaggerating.
You know, whichever
side you're on,
it ought to be possible,
in my judgment, given
the issues at stake
here, for people to say,
well, yes, you've got a good
point there, I see that,
and that's why you
want to stay in.
But here's another argument
that really matters to me.
And that's why, in the end,
I'm going to vote to leave.
And the other person can say,
well, you know, I accept.
There is an argument
for leaving.
But actually, this argument
is more important to me.
So I'm going to vote to stay in.
That is the basis on which the
debate should be carried out.
The idea that it's blindingly
obvious what the answer is--
the only problem is
that half of the people
think it's blindingly
obvious we should stay in
and the other half
it's blindingly
obvious we should leave.
This is treating
people as idiots.
And actually, we have a jury
system to try people in court.
Why?
Not because these people
are technical experts,
but because ordinary people
have a pretty good ability
to judge when someone's
telling the truth.
And what I do think is that
a referendum is only sensible
if people are given the chance
to make up their own mind.
Otherwise, there'll be a
call for the same referendum
all over again in a year or
two, when some other development
takes place.
So that's all I'm going to say.
MALE SPEAKER: Lovely.
We will leave it there,
in the essence of time.
Oh, we've got one
very quick question.
One very quick question.
Maybe something lighthearted?
AUDIENCE: It's not
super lighthearted,
but I'll make it a
little bit different.
So you spoke about the value
of floating exchange rates
to act as a shock absorber
in various economies.
Why do you think it is
that the US dollar works,
or does it work, for
such a diverse country,
you know, over 300 million
people living there,
very different industries
across the states.
Why does that union work?
MERVYN KING: Well,
very briefly, it's
partly because people move
all around the United States.
If one part of the
US economy suffers
because it can't change
its exchange rate,
then what you need
to do is some people
have to emigrate and leave,
and people don't worry too much
about that.
And because through one
mechanism or another,
whether it's social
security or the tax system,
the richer parts, the more
successful parts of the US,
will actually transfer
resources to the poorer parts.
But even within
the United States,
there are parts which
are clearly economically
unsuccessful, deprived
almost, and bits
which are very successful.
The fundamental thing is that
no one in the US says look,
I'm not American.
I don't come from New York,
and I resent these people,
you know, failing
to pay me money
or telling me how to run
our taxes and spending here.
People feel American.
And one of the
chapters of the book
talks about the link
between money and nation.
And over a very
long period, there
has been a remarkable one to one
correspondence between nations
and their monies.
And I think that
is not an accident.
It's because if you live in
one nation and feel part of it,
you're willing to accept
the decision of a majority,
that the outcome is one
that you will accept,
and you won't rise up
in rebellion against it.
And that's of
fundamental importance.
And that's true
within a country,
and it's not true
between countries.
MALE SPEAKER: Great.
Please join me in a
massive round of applause
in thanking Lord Mervyn King.
[APPLAUSE]